you can't expect your kid to be a better
person than you are I had this situation
with my 7-year-old son this morning
where he did something very out of line
and I was initially pretty ticked off
when I heard about it but I told him
okay you need to stand there in the
corner until I'm ready to talk to you I
left the room so I could calm down a
second so I could actually approach this
like an adult and then I talked to him
and I administered what the consequences
were going to be for the action but
whatever the punishment is you shouldn't
be angry while you're ad ministering it
now in reality dayto day you're going to
get ticked off at your kids it's going
to happen like it happens to everybody
but when you go in and just like pissed
off then you're just taking your anger
out on your kid and that's not parenting
that's just you venting so many of the
problems you have with kids is that
they're not able to control their
emotions and they're not able to react
rationally to frustration but if you are
demonstrating a similar inability to
control your emotions how can you expect
anything better from them